[Music]
community college enrollment is down but
skilled trades programs are booming
so this is a educational hey get
qualified to make more money bigger
shovel
and boy oh boy this the sands are
shifting all right here's a quick
snapshot where we are since the pandemic
begin
so let's call it uh what march 2020.
uh more than a million students have
held off from going to college opting to
go to work instead
uh our last caller 18 year old oh yeah
he graduated in 2021 kids making money
selling shoes
by the way i guess i should call back to
that kelly did pull up the air force
ones the off-white air force ones that i
was looking at
not for me
wow all right the deal is off bryce the
deal is off bryce well we still want you
to do everything else that george told
you to do
uh so bryce is an example though of here
he is he's out making money very
entrepreneurial
hasn't gone to school yet
uh two-year public schools have been
among the hardest hit that we're talking
about community colleges down about
three-quarters of a million students
george
that's 750 million george if you're
keeping thank you for the math on that
skilled trades programs are the
exception across the country associates
degree programs in fields like hvac and
automotive repair are swelling this from
npr
of this article i'm citing
now another area george that i think for
people that are handy and they're going
hey i want a side hustle
maybe a weekend gig
uh maybe if you've got a different kind
of a shift maybe you're working nights
and you want to make some money if you
know how to swing a hammer
oh yeah construction man huge there's a
shortage in qualified construction
workers
according to a september 2021 survey
of the associated general contractors of
america the survey found that 89 of
contractors are having a difficult time
finding workers who were trained for the
job that affects project timelines of
course 61 of contractors reported
project delays
because of workforce
shortages ken you're gonna love this one
the federal government only spends a
dollar on career training for every six
dollars it puts into college prep wow
so we're preparing kids for college for
the two to four years and nothing beyond
that nothing uh and uh so let me just
give this a little bit of real
main street application
okay
let me tell you what a skilled
okay i don't mean like college school
we're talking about trades if you're
good with a power saw a hammer all that
kind of stuff stuff that you don't know
you know what i'm talking about to do
that you pay people and eat ice cream
while they do it
all right
you're looking at 250 bucks a day
right now in williamson county that air
this area around nashville 250 bucks a
day that's good money that's a minimum
so you know you're looking for that side
hustle george make some money to get out
of debt and here's the other thing um
what we're seeing is is the reason that
people are pulling away from community
colleges are becoming less and less
relevant
as opposed to going straight to a trade
school including technology schools
meaning not a traditional four-year
college but uh ultimately some type of
boot camp like bethel tech yeah which is
a nine-month program well the big thing
is people are rethinking the value of
college and this means securing a
high-paying job without taking on too
much debt because as we know the trades
are a really affordable way to get the
education you need to get the skills you
need to then get a really high paying
job at the end of that that's right so
big fan of the trades